a lot of people don't don't know my
story but
the way i grew up we we had a lot of
struggle with face a lot of challenges
uh eight and a half years ago like six
months before i came to the league we
were trying to figure out where we're
gonna get our next meal from
you know i saw my parents every day
sacrifice worked extremely hard
to provide for us you know and growing
up
i always wanted my my family to have a
better life for them
i wanted my brothers to have a better
life than me and
i wanted my next and my my kids
to have a better life than what i had so
i worked extremely hard when i came
when i came to the league i said okay
you know i'm 18 years old
nobody believes in me nobody thinks i
can make it i'm going to work extremely
hard every single day
i'm going to walk wake up every day with
a goal in my mind
you know it might be a crazy goal but
i'm going to have the goal in my mind
and i'm going to do whatever
it possibly takes to achieve that goal
if i have to stay in the gym
six hours eight hours ten hours if i if
i have to
run more than the other guys if no
matter what i have to do
i'm gonna do it and you know step by
step
things were just happening you know uh i
got stronger i had people that believed
in me
you know i had people that pushed me
throughout the whole journey and i was
seeing things
i was seeing things like okay this this
puzzle of life
it's coming together now like i i i can
i can achieve this
and um and i never stop working you know
even now that
this is how messed up my my brain is
even today that um
we won the nba championship i wasn't in
i wasn't in the team photo
i went in the back i just had to sit
down
talk to my brothers a little bit i was
just trying to figure out
you know when we're going to come back
when you're going to do it again
exactly and and and you know that that's
the mindset
i have and that's who i am
and that's what made me great that's
what made this team great and uh
i'm going to keep you know try to stay
humble and just keep
keep as you said when you get to the top
of the mountain a lot of people want to
come get with you
what you have and uh and but at the end
of the day
even if they get it it's okay you know
but i'm going to
extremely work i think i have a lot of
things that i can improve in my game
and uh hopefully i can help my team win
next year too
gets inside and finishes oh he makes it
look so easy
takes it away and throws it down he will
not be stopped
what is your goal for your career owner
nba nba giannis
[Music]
i will give everything i will prove to
my working box
but i make the right choice
[Music]
[Applause]
oh this rookie can play he has a bright
the future basketball god
that man is defense player of the year
now got to show that man some respect
where i started and where i am right now
it's been a long journey
you can never take these moments for
granted
[Music]
[Applause]
throws it down giannis on the alley-oop
what a turnaround
[Music]
truly one of the most extraordinary
stories in the history of professional
sports
he does it again tonight with a 50-point
masterpiece
one of five boys from athens greece the
tight
knit loving family had very little
growing up was a street vendor back in
athens
sold dvds and cds didn't play basketball
until he was 12.
but as you saw there he said his dream
like millions of kids was to play in the
nba
and not only is he playing in the nba
one of the most remarkable players this
game has ever seen
he's still only 26 he's been an all-star
and mvp
and now he's an nba champion
such an emotional evening foreign
and his family
a spectacular performance to finish off
this unbelievable season there with his
boy
[Music]
as we welcome you again back here to the